lo strumento del potere
questo quello è lo strumento della terra
puoi comandare me con quel va bene bene
a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo magnifico video con gian andrea
ciao ciao sono molto emozionato ma anche
io
non è la prima volta che vengo qui sennò
come se fosse la prima presa è un video
molto importante allora stiamo per
giocare ragazzi a spider man miles
morales sono qui con ma il morale sotto
la voce italiana di mais morale sono
inaridite quindi non solo quest'anno i
primi gameplay italiani di spiderman
perché i mega anteprima ma anche con il
signor gian andrea quindi credito che si
agganci di lorenzo credibile così questa
è la prima volta et altro vedi la
playstation simco ok quindi funziona che
ti schiaccio i tasti mento e si apre un
mondo di cose che però forse non posso
far vedere più ma allora premessa io non
ho giocato al bridge o giocato il primo
ma non tutta la storia per forza fare il
momento viene lui e miles morales lui e
miles morales tv o mais nel primo entra
nella vita di peter perché il padre che
era un poliziotto che dava una mano
peter spider man è morto durante un
attentato ad opera del cattivo del primo
gioco dopo la morte del padre
la madre cercato di riprendersi lui per
non piuttosto che andare in terapia
preferito andare a fare volontariato ed
ha dovuto fare volontariato nel centro
di relazioni peter dedizione canon un
centro per rifugiati senza tetto e
simili
egli ha conosciuto peter brook e che poi
è stato morso anche le dove al miur ed
attivo e vitali ha insegnato essere
spider man
ci siamo allora bellissimo perché ti fa
il punto della storia se la vuoi fare
devi non mai è già fatto due articolo
andiamo dai tagli ascolto fedeltà
doppiaggio inglese
no qui lo volevo dire proprio il fatto
che non essendo piace inglesi in
apertura quindi no no mais morale
squadre che dovremmo fare questa non
mettere doppia dire allora abbiamo
questa perla a questa è la partenza ok
il mondo sono semi entrati sotto natale
sin verdi si capiva ma vabbè che new
york fa sempre freddo ma comunque non ti
sto in questo punto io non posso dirti
certe robe perché non lo capiresti se
non si sente tutto quello che succede
dal controller cela la m alle fermate la
sentivi quindi adesso sentirà la musica
delle pustole si sente proprio tutto
quello che succede a livello di feeling
di controller tipo ad essere passato
l'autobus sento meravigliosa questa cosa
perché sia morales tutta sta roba perché
la madre di mais e si sta camminando
come sindaco nino de nada data prima
battuta il de nada e degli e mezzi
spagnolo avendo messicano è ficcata
incredibile
a mano e il vecchio spider ti aiuta
grazie di niente ei pensi di aggiungere
anche il nuovo spider man
ecco il ragazzino forse anche preferisco
originale sai
sì lo so ma poverino la bottega di deo e
qui vicino c'è un segno già la prima
avanti è facile grazie bel lavoro
comunque uno spazietto per l'altro non
si sa mai
poverino ha fatto la bellezza
incredibile realizzato
questo insomma chi è che fa i costumi di
spider man se non lo sai credo peter
stessa lui al sarto ci siamo this is
allora tu avendo giocato bene ho giocato
anche l'altro un po però sai bene tullio
la differenza differenza c'è un in ogni
mini nel caso come le notare a me fa
impazzire comunque questa roba qua che
c'era anche nell'altro che dentro sono
rendering come cacchio è il guardian
riflesso oltretutto di peter lui nel
sistema dopo fantastica sta roba
c'è questa cosa poi veramente strana mi
ha permesso e mi ha fatto un effetto
incredibile
ovviamente tutte queste frasi che lui
sta dicendo che le dice penso quando
cazzeggia in giro c'è tu l'hai lei dette
senza vedere nulla ci è andato era
puramente colonne audio semplicemente
vevo l'audio davanti e risentivo laudi e
quindi rita la cavo ok ma ecco quella
cosa che io volevo veramente chiederti e
l'effetto che può fare perché comunque
questo è il tuo penso primo lavoro di
questo calibro c'è questo quando
privandoli osta si è un gioco di questo
gioco di punta sony quindi immagino sia
non appagante vedersi risultato finito
di più che è una roba incredibile questa
che io sono veramente veramente stato
contento anche perché quando ho doppiato
miles nel primo spider man io sapevo
cos'era destinato mais cioè diventare
spider man
però non mi immaginavo poi un gioco da
protagonista sì tu dici vabbè non
succede ma se succede
ma peter in tutto questo sperando un
caffè
bene con molta molta attenzione
ok si va
li beve a testa in giù la cosa
incredibile è abituato allora chiedo
innanzitutto già scusa ai puristi di
spider man
perché mi vedranno combattere una
maniera di poco oscena ma non avendo
appunto cielo giocato il primo ma non
tutto è tanto tempo fa quindi già
profonda riuscito un minuto col cliente
mi dispiace ma anzi meglio
qua è mai se le prime armi ci sta che
anche tutte le sere primi anni la brava
rassicura la gente si speriamo
lui uomo a donna una proiezione mirata
questo
non è vero sono passato dentro un
edificio bellissima se lo farai a quanto
capitolo farei stesso pezzo bellissimo
pensa che si batte farsi tutti interni
mamma ma donna però bara garics khrin
comunque si sente sempre a male
compreso un url in faccia amata almeno
evitato quello mi sembra più ma è meglio
un in faccia che un muro lanciato in
francia per avere mamma mia come impara
subito questa slide
non è vero di socio scusate
ebbene sì esatto quello che va al
contrario vero
ok si sono morti in duemila ma non
panieri a volume di toni e meno male per
archi a peter katie lee salvo non male
madonna ragazzi ad arese schiacciato
giusto ecco sai cos'è che una roba che
io non ho mai capito perché la mia il
mio serie videogiocatore me lo impedisce
se tu sbagli un quick time event e non
posso farlo perché più forte di me cosa
succede gli schiaccia veramente avrebbe
schiacciato la carrozzina in spagna
minuti lo so dire
ma secondo menti cosa camera si gira
verso un no il successo di rimuovere
dalla minaccia è una mente fragile
molto natalizio detenuti
[Musica]
[Applauso]
min cartelloni bene
big ben
il mio amico
spegna su
[Musica]
ariston spider man e crew vorrei
cambiarlo con uno
questo può andare
già
vattene via
levy
a stare peggio
[Musica]
min che cos'è
pugno venom
questo pugno fortissimo sì perché il
ragno che ha morso mais
è una specie di radio particolare sono
ragni letteralmente esistenti non core e
che possono condurre l'elettricità e la
usavano per farla passare veneto per
l'inter è giusto dire lepre verso e il
ragno geneticamente modificato abbiamo
quindi a questa cosa che spider man
normale non ha esatto bellissimo dati
mais è meno forte fisicamente di peter
megafono
[Musica]
no
quindi ti posso fare
ok se non voglio che il professor mondo
ok va bene bravo
da ricordi pieno registrato tipo 50 ore
di stage 86 vivo più o meno
ragazzi wow wow simon krieger capo
sviluppo della roxon energy è un piacere
piacere scusa ci è finita la palla nel
tuo cortile no
vi devo un favore abbiamo appena
rilevato la proprietà e dovevamo
comunque demolirla ma siete stati i più
veloci di noi
vi ringrazio entrambi ha esteso rhino da
solo
farai strada ragazza grazie ma è ancora
pericoloso
ora lo diamo alla polizia sapete a volte
penso che questi soldati non servano ma
poi succede questo il dovere chiama ei è
stato un piacere conoscervi l'alba del
futuro
ovviamente non c'è la conta giusta o
sono io pazzo non puoi dirci niente se
non penso il miglioramento di mesi
abbiamo intuito non credo che mi ci
abituerò mai il regalo di natale da
spiderman che bello che lui e fan ti
copro io
sì sì tanto meno 20 gradi ho mai visto
nessuno cambiarsi a central park come
mista con le adidas congratulazioni e
benvenuto al tuo primissimo supercostume
ma perché ce ne sono vari ok per avere
costruire la tv almeno nemmeno costumi
succede a questo meno per conto della
baia nord per la seconda parte del tuo
regalo o qui appunto ci sono tutti
quanti vari costumi che sono ovviamente
bloccati a te li fa che vedere
bellissimo madonna questo fantastici
guarda questo qua è bellissimo
madonna che sensazioni incredibili deve
provare a fare i trick mentre 6 10 premi
viene premuto quadrato e nuovi
l'analogico
a livello di feeling fin ora che hai
provato come allora è come vecchio
spider e quindi funziona veramente bene
c'è già il primo era un trionfo di
gameplay a livello di fluidità inventiva
e simili cioè ha preso una formula che
già abbiamo visto funzionare e la resa
sua è un pò più spettacolare e adesso
che c'è il secondo regalo di spider man
è solo che appunto con il controller
senti tutto un po di più
ciao mi chiamo simon cracker e quello
che hai davanti agli occhi è un reattore
nuvole quando sarà attivo questo
reattore soddisferanno intero fabbisogno
energetico di tutta la lega come mai
impossibile e la risposta è no forma
jason placement ma cos'è la moto mi fa
impazzire solo per rientrare dentro
ecco
non ti fa male è questo domani in onda
in due la madonna prato che bella new
york
quanta gente sono questi
no non mi dispiace miles una tonalità
quante armi esistono in questo mondo è
loro ne hanno parecchie e mori tutto
finito col rovinare
non so non ho capito niente scappa e
prendi lo avrò ok giusto è sempre lì
circa poi istantaneo voluto
sostenendo il colpo vena mi sia mai che
qualcuno decide di madonna che dolore
fortissimo e tu l'energia cos'era il
corto venute con per curare meglio la
cura ormai è lodevole in questa che al
tipo low light dai dovrebbe essere quasi
finito volevo fare questa cosa ed è
successa questa cosa biden
ecco volevo chiederti ma quelli casa col
muro sono capote posticipare le loro
mosse
chi non è che si liberano dopo un po
seguivano i carichi di forma davvero
questo feeling da pigiamino 0 ora tocca
allora
molto bene è stato splendido questo è
palesemente deceduto proprio il costume
più o meno a il dotto un potenziamento a
un potenziamento di questo 4 puoi
sbloccarlo e aumentare i primi 10 25 per
cento i danni invece ama quindi base al
costume ai delle dei perk allora ogni
costume ha una sua visita peculiare che
però quei dare anche dal tribunale
capitale quindi 13 gen i ragazzi che
sarà spiderman mais morales con
gianandrea che è mais morale spero che
vi sia piaciuto passato anche da chi già
anche troppo in descrizione io vi
ringrazio per la visione grazie anche
alla sony per aver per la playstation
per spider man per tutto se vuoi avermi
scelto che avete scelto lui se volete
venire a fare il video al posto mio
va bene prossima volta e noi ci riuniamo
come sempre ad un prossimo video da
ragazzi
[Musica]